Now that we have the game mode created,
let's go ahead and talk about Blueprint interfaces.
Now, Blueprint interfaces are a special way
that you can very cheaply send information
to and from various actors inside of Unreal Engine 5.
We create our interfaces by right-clicking inside
of the content browser, going to Blueprints,
and then selecting a Blueprint interface.
When we create this Blueprint interface,
you're going to notice that the graph is similar but slightly
different.
That's because with these Blueprint interfaces,
we are defining a method of communication.
So what we're doing is we're basically
defining the objects or the inputs and outputs
that we want this interface to interact with.
And then instead of having to cast to multiple Blueprints
or load up multiple Blueprints just
to work with this information, we
can just make sure that it has this interface.
So what we're going to do now is we're
going to go into the editor, and we're
going to make an interface.
And then in our interface, what we're going to do
is we're going to add two integer inputs called
score and time.
So let's pop over to the editor, and let's do that now.
So I'm going to hit Control-Space,
and for some reason, there we go, that is pulling up now.
And I'm going to come up here to my content folder.
I'm just going to do this at the root of it,
and I'm going to right-click.
We're going to go Blueprints, and we're
going to go Blueprint Interface.
Now, I like to label these for BPI, or Blueprint Interface,
and we're going to call this one.
And let's double-click on it to open it up.
And again, there is going to be no way for us
to draw or drag off of this.
We do have the ability to name our function here.
So we're going to go ahead and call this pickUpObject.
And then what we're going to do is
we're going to come to our inputs,
and we're going to add 1 and 2.
And so we're going to call one of them score,
and we're going to call the other one time.
And we also need to make sure that we
set these to be integers, because our score and our time
are going to be integer values.
And it looked like I took my time there,
so there we go.
So let's go ahead and compile and save.
Now, once we have our interface created,
we need to let whatever we want to interact with
know about where that interface is.
And to do this, what we're going to do
is we're going to locate our advanced vehicle
pawn, because that is the pawn that we're
going to be controlling.
We're going to open it up, and we're
going to go to its class settings.
And then inside of its class settings,
there is this option called Implemented Interfaces.
We are going to implement this interface.
So let's pop back over to the editor now.
And I can go ahead and close this.
Let me just make sure that I've saved it.
Great.
We're going to close this.
And I'm going to hit Control-Space again
to bring up my content browser, which there we go.
We're going to our vehicle template, our Blueprint.
And then we're going to look for our vehicle advanced pawn,
and I'm going to double-click on that to open it up.
Then inside of our class settings,
we're going to go over here to our Implemented.
Then we're going to click on this Add.
And if we just search for VPI, here we go.
There's our VPI stats.
And we've added there.
Let's compile and save.
And if we have done this correctly,
we will see this pickup interface object right here.
The next thing that we need to do
is we need to actually set up this little bit of logic
inside of our vehicle pawn.
And we're going to basically make this a little bit of code.
So what we're going to do is set this up.
So let's go ahead and pop back over to our editor
really quick.
And we are going to be doing this inside of the pawn.
So I'm just going to come down here probably
to the bottom.
There we go.
And we're going to look for event.
And we want the VPI event.
So let's just call this VPI stats.
So we're going to look for event.
And then there we go.
Event pickup object.
The event pickup object is what we want there.
And then what we're going to do is
we need to also create a new variable.
And we're going to call this new variable current score.
We're going to change it to an integer.
integer.
Let's compile and save so that we can have this current
score integer ready.
And then what we're going to do
is we're going to pull this out.
And we are going to get the current score.
And what do we want to do with the current score?
Well, we want to take the score.
And we're going to go plus.
I'm going to hold down shift to get a plus there.
I said shift.
There we go.
And there's our ad.
So we're going to take our score.
And then we're going to add that to our current score.
And then what we're going to do
is we're going to take this current score.
And we're going to drag this out.
And we're going to go set.
So basically, we're going to get the current score.
If we score, we're going to take that current score.
We're going to add to it.
And then what we're going to do
is we're going to set the current score to that new value.
Now, what we're going to do next
is we are going to get our time.
But remember, our time is set in our game mode.
So what we're going to do is we're going to get game.
Oops, and it'd help if I would spell that right.
So get game mode.
There we go.
So there's our get game mode.
And then from our game mode, we
are going to cast to advanced vehicle game mode.
And we're going to actually right click on this
and convert this to a pure cast.
The reason we're doing this is it allows
us to not have to do it in validation check
on this particular one.
Since we know that we are specifically
going to this particular advanced vehicle game mode,
and we know that the value is in there,
we can use this like this without having
to actually put in a check to see
if this cast is going to fail.
Then what we're going to do is
we're going to pull off of this,
and we're going to look for time.
We are going to get our time remaining because we
want to get what time is left.
And then similarly to what we did up here,
where we have this going out and then setting
our current score, we're going to do
the same thing with our time.
So basically what we're going to do
is we're going to take our time remaining,
and we are going to plus add our time.
And I'm going to flip these nodes around like this.
So there we go.
So we take our time, and then we
add that to our time remaining.
And then we are going to look for that time.
And there we go, set time remaining.
And then we're just going to connect this current score
to our set time remaining.
We're going to plug the add into the time remaining.
And the target is actually going
to be coming from our vehicle advanced game mode.
So let's clean this up really quick
to make it a little bit easier to read.
So we're going to pull this down, set this up like so.
One of the cool things you can do with your Blueprint
wires to make things a little bit easier to read
is we can double click on a wire
and add what's known as a reroute.
And a reroute is just going to make it a little bit easier
to see where that wire is going.
It doesn't add anything additional to your Blueprint.
It's not going to make it run slower or faster
or anything like that.
It's just going to make it easier to see what's going on.
And as you're seeing here, I like
to put variables underneath the addition pin.
That's just a personal preference of mine.
So there we go.
That is our final setup right here.
So we have our event pickup object.
And then based on that pickup object,
whether it is going to give a score or time,
we are going to either set our time, our current score, which
is going to be inside of the vehicle pond,
or set our time, which is inside of our game mode.
So that does it for this part.
Make sure you compile and save.
And we will see you in the next part of this video
tutorial series, setting up our score and time pickup.